putins satan raketen sie klingen
wirklich wie aus der hölle die rakete
hat eine reichweite von 18.000
kilometern und ist mit atomaren
sprengköpfen bestückter heißt mit ihr
kann russland sowohl über den nord- als
auch über den südpol angreifen und ziele
weltweit erreichen je länger der krieg
gegen die ukraine dauert umso mehr
meldungen über eine angebliche russische
wunderwaffe jetzt hat russland eine neue
superwaffe angekündigt bis zum herbst
sollen neue nukleare raketen zum einsatz
kommen vom typ satan zwei so der name
der nato für die neuen russischen
interkontinentalraketen
die rakete soll eine reichweite von
18.000 kilometern haben und mit atomaren
sprengköpfen bestückt war sein putins
satan raketen für ukrainische präsident
volume lenski nur ein neues propaganda
manöver der russen um das zu
verdeutlichen nutzte sie lenski in einem
interview jetzt ein deutsches wort
bekannt aus der nazi propaganda in der
propaganda von nazi deutschland gab es
ein begriff wie unter wasser was erst
vor kurzem kündigten die russen den
einsatz von laser waffen an vor ein paar
tagen dann die meldung über die neue
rakete bis ende herbst will russland 50
neue super raketen vom typ sa matt in
den dienst nehmen ende april hatte
russland auf dem russischen
weltraumbahnhof plesetsk einen test
abschuss mit einer matt rakete
durchgeführt
ukraine ist präsident ist überzeugt nach
drei monaten erbitterte kämpfe versucht
russland nun mit einer neuen wunderwaffe
die welt einzuschüchtern sind putin
start an raketen also nur ein propaganda
trick oder können sie wirklich die wende
im krieg herbeiführen
und unser militärexperte juliane koepcke
ist jetzt hier bei uns im studio und von
ihr könnt ihr mehr informationen über
diese vermeintliche superwaffe bekommen
julian das steckt dahinter
tatsächlich also seit dem ausbruch des
krieges ist russland ja bemüht immer zu
sagen wir haben hier neue sachen wir
haben eine neue waffen die können uns
noch weiterhelfen die
art wie sie auf russisch heißt oder
satan zwei das ist ja nato code name
wenn man so möchte ist tatsächlich eine
waffe die russland bereits seit fünf
jahren etwa entwickelt und immer wieder
gesagt hat die haben wir bald die ampel
bald im april wurde sie dann tatsächlich
zum ersten mal getestet und jetzt ist
man natürlich bemüht immer weitere gute
nachrichten in anführungsstrichen gute
nachrichten zu ihr zu haben die neue
gute nachricht ist dass die rakete
bereits aus einer massenproduktion ende
des jahres in dienst gehen soll und
weitere 46 davon gebaut werden soll wie
wir gesagt haben tatsächlich ist es noch
geräte mit sehr hoher reichweite 18.000
kilometer wir das in russland ist ein
riesiges land und man kann abhängig
davon wo man die rakete abfeuerte jedem
punkt der welt damit erreichen werden
dass gerade selber gesagt die
ankündigung immer neuer wunderwaffen
einen krieg wie ernst muss man solche
äußerungen nehmen ja also ich denke wie
so oft ist es eine nachricht nach innen
vor allem um der eigenen bevölkerung zu
sagen ja das ist die vielleicht nicht so
gut aus für uns wir haben kirchen nicht
erobert für staeck nahen osten fest wir
haben 20 30.000 tote auf eigener seite
arbeit wir haben weiterhin gute
nachrichten für euch gute neuigkeiten
insofern nach innen natürlich wichtig
dass man sagt wir sind ein militär kraft
nach außen denke ich als auch schon eine
bedeutung weil man ja dem westen immer
wieder signalisiert ja ihr denkt wir
sind nur in der ukraine aber guck mal
parallel beschäftigen wir uns mit der
zerstörung der welt wenn man so möchte
denn ein atomkrieg also man muss sich
das ja klar machen sollte diese rakete
jemals zum einsatz kommen gibt es danach
weder in washington noch in berlin noch
in moskau überlebende ja oder vielleicht
ein paar leute in bunkern insofern ist
das natürlich ein sehr sehr
theoretisches szenario was da was da
gemacht wird von russland aber eben
eines wo man ja stichwort dritter
weltkrieg haben einige ja auch vor angst
wie wir wissen wo man eben doch immer
wieder punkte macht und menschen mit
erschrecken kann zumindest also glaubst
du das könnte jetzt wirklich
kriegsentscheidend seien es die waffe
überhaupt so schnell fertig oder ist das
eigentlich eine rhetorik die auch daraus
entsteht dass putin entdeckt dass dieser
krieg nicht so läuft wer das eigentlich
geplant hatte ja ich denke dass das
letztere ist es eher kriegsentscheidend
sicher nicht weil wir nicht davon
ausgehen können dass er atomwaffen in
der ukraine einsetzt natürlich und
selbst wenn die einsätzen wurde bräuchte
er nicht die weil die ukraine maximal an
weitesten punkt vielleicht 1000
kilometer von russland entfernt ist und
nicht 18.000 kilometer insofern hat das
hier mit dem krieg erst mal an sich
nichts zu tun und wir haben es schon
angesprochen
es ist auch für propaganda dabei es ist
überhaupt nicht klar ob diese rakete
ende des jahres wirklich einsatzbereit
ist also einer davon haben wir gesehen
okay aber es ist hier ein zu gibt es
noch mehr und außerdem ist es so dass
auch allein die technischen daten
überhaupt nicht westliche experten
bislang überzeugen russland sagt das
sind 15 atomsprengköpfe gründen die alle
überall über der welt sozusagen
abgelassen werden kann amerikanische
experten haben sich das genauer angucken
und sagen das sind maximal szenen die
sie darin vermuten und die auch wenn
einmal losgelassen sozusagen nicht auf
verschiedene ziele verteilt werden
können sondern er da wo die rakete sowie
so einschlägt insofern wollen wir hoffen
dass sie niemals zum einsatz kommt das
glaube ich das wichtigste aber selbst
wenn sie zum einsatz käme gibt es große
zweifel an ihrer wirklichen überragen
halt die russland behauptet
vielen dank für diese aktuellen wirklich
sehr interessante eindrücke ich mich
dann robbte unser bild militärexperte